the jurgen experience you do you know
the story
about this guy who is a a liberal
journalist
who what did he do he agreed with
someone that said something he likes
something
about alexandria ocasio-cortez and the
police came
to his house did you hear this story i
did pull this story up because it's
so crazy crazy that you you go this
can't be real
now i don't think that it's aoc who's
doing this
it's probably some [ __ ] nutty aoc
reporter
or uh supporter rather police visit the
home of podcaster
after it criticized aoc on twitter so
pull up the story because
this is so crazy this is like so crazy
communist china type [ __ ]
it's so crazy that i feel like there has
to be more to it when i heard about it
the other night but
no it's not yeah screw please scroll
down so i could read this
here it goes no no no so i could read
that oh yeah it's about that interview
that she had which was
see yeah the the interview was [ __ ]
awesome it's so ridiculous
on april 1st aoc did a live stream with
michael miller the head of the jewish
community relations council of new york
she was asked about peace between
israelis and palestinians her response
was incredibly underwhelming
to say the very least now if you listen
to her response
she's unprepared she doesn't really have
a thing to say about this so she
basically just sort of uses word salad
and it's a nonsense answer okay but no
go back down go back right there
um really shaken up right now uh so the
guy puts this thing saying it's
underwhelming he puts it up on twitter
and i'm really shaken right now this is
the next tweet
i was just visited by two plainclothes
police officers from california
highway patrol at my home they said they
came here
on behalf of the capitol police and
accused me of threatening aoc on twitter
yesterday
this is provably false so go back up to
what we just saw
so this is all he said her response was
incredibly underwhelming
to say the very least so someone decided
that what he's
now the reason being is i'm sure
this is some sort of a supporter of aoc
that contacted the capitol hill police
and probably lied but the fact that they
could just come to your [ __ ] house
without any proof that you it's not like
he's saying this
lady deserves to die she must be stopped
we have to stop
none of that none of that none of that
underwhelming to say the least
which is a very mild criticism it is
especially if you watch that interview
the guy's face is classic though the guy
interviewing
it's just like he can't believe what
she's saying it's classic people watch
his facial expressions
but we should play it just so people
understand
what how because it is it's really a
ridiculous answer
but it's it's it's the kind of answer
you give when you're in seventh grade
and you're doing a uh you like the
teacher asked you a question about a
book report you didn't really read the
book
exactly what it was about columbus and
this is it was so important that
columbus was here because without
columbus
there were so many things that would not
have happened you know
what columbus did was brave and amazing
you know yeah really that's exactly what
it is
now you have to be careful they might be
showing up at your house tonight they
might be at the studio when we're when
we walk out of here i don't think aoc
does i really don't i think it's a crazy
person
that thinks that this is just my opinion
i think it was most likely a crazy
person
that is angry at this guy for not toeing
the liberal line
because he's a liberal journalist yeah
podcaster
that's the interesting thing too when
you talk about you know growing up when
we grew up when you talk about
liberalism it means something different
than it does today and there's a
difference between a classical liberal
and
a leftist and what we're seeing more of
in this country is those terms
intertwined and they're very different
things yes
and leftists are kind of what we're
seeing more of uh which is
grabbing this control restrictions on
freedom of speech
restrictions on owning firearms
restrictions on whatever they think
might be quote unquote dangerous
yeah especially when they throw in
dangerous to the children that's the
other other key when uh talking about it
but then
they take power and guess who's back
she's buying all the expensive houses
and has that has the power and the
control oh those same people that were
fighting for the little guy a little
while ago and talking about all these
restrictions that we needed to place
on uh some of these more natural rights
that uh are inherent at birth
namely to be able to defend ourselves
and our family defend that gift of life
yeah like when a marxist starts making
money and buys million dollar houses ah
did that happen recently yeah it did
yeah yeah that's what happens yeah
you're a marxist if you're a marxist
you're not buying million dollar houses
you're not on a [ __ ] real estate bank
that's not marxism that's why i talk to
well all that
as often as i possibly can i talk about
the importance of studying our history
putting that requisite time
energy and effort into studying the past
so we can make decisions
that uh because we have this
responsibility to make decisions
uh for future generations and if we
haven't put that time into studying our
history and if what you know about a
certain
uh event or a a certain issue
is based on someone else's tweet that
you just retweeted and all of a sudden
that's your opinion of something that's
going to affect multiple generations
down the line particularly
their abilities to defend themselves and
their families or to to start a business
or whatever
it might be well you owe it to put down
the phone to get into these books
realize
hey why why why are these amendments in
place why is this important
um and from the inception of this
country up until today people have died
to give you the right to be able to make
these decisions to follow your dreams to
have these options and opportunities not
only yeah
everything people have died supporting
these things that you support
these things you like when people are
really into marxism like
you need to learn what happened when
that was the rule of law
because it's a terrible terrible history
it's horrible but it seems good like the
idea that everybody should have
something
it should be equal for all and all the
workers should be even and everybody
should have equal things well
you know what happens then you you don't
have the same amount of effort because
there's a reason why some people work
harder than others
because they realize you can actually
get further ahead there's a competition
and that competition fuels innovation
it fuels all sorts of things there's
incentives there's incentives to
discipline
you wake up an hour earlier then you're
the next guy you do it seven days a week
you've got seven hours of work
that guy doesn't have it yep or you wake
up seven hours earlier like jacob does
and everybody else something like that
yeah
uh but yeah you have that option yeah i
can write books you can do this like we
have these amazing freedoms and
when have you ever read a book whether
fiction or non or studied history where
the people that put names on lists the
people that restrict rights the people
that confiscate firearms are the good
guys
in any of those movies even let's just
say fiction yeah exactly yeah
exactly so that should be a clue right
there seems like when you say it the
right way
if you restrict the rights of these
people to have guns then they'll
not be any mass shootings because
there'll be no guns like oh okay and
someone just retweets that that becomes
their opinion rather than hold on let me
look at the
if this was even the issue uh hey let me
look at the look at the fbi crime
statistics the actual ones and be like
oh
why are they going after this one thing
that causes almost nothing they should
be going after hammers and baseball bats
or if they really wanted to save lives
you should make sure that every single
phone
just turned off when you got in your car
and just didn't wasn't allowed to
operate if you really cared about the
children
or at least start 18 and under no
texting this thing turns off when you
get a car if you're really concerned
about saving lives so it's a
disingenuous argument from
the beginning but it sounds so good
catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience